[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie we have the
best news about daredevil season 3 we
just got that Iron Fist trailer and
everyone's like wait a minute
Iron Fist what about daredevil when is
daredevil coming when now we actually
know so we got to break this down if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this it was a big netflix earnings
call where Reed Hastings was talking to
investors about what was going on with
the rest of the year in amongst the
programs that he said that they would be
dropping before the end of the year he
mentioned daredevil season 3 so I know
it's a little bit weird because we're
getting Iron Fist in September and
that's already pretty late in the year
so you're like wait a minute when are
they going to be dropping daredevil
what's going on with this it is time for
him to be born again there were a couple
specific scenes during Luke Cage season
2 and the Iron Fist trailers that we've
seen so far that referenced what's going
on with daredevil but what's been
happening this year is that Netflix has
been dropping new Marvel series every
three months or so so Jessica Jones
dropped in March then in June we got
Luke Cage three months after that we're
getting iron fist
so you can set your clocks for about
three months after iron fist drops which
puts it at the end of November beginning
of December but here's the reason why I
think that it's going to be that first
week in December is because Netflix
really likes to drop their family fare
the week of Thanksgiving like fuller
house is a good example of a
family-friendly program that people are
together for the holidays before you
move into December for all those
holidays many different religions have
holidays that take place in December but
remember daredevil is a Catholic his
faith is very important to the character
so it's always a big part of the series
and that means Christianity Christmas
the birth of Christ
daredevil reborn so it starts to make
more sense why they're waiting til the
Christmas season to drop daredevil
season 3 because of what happened during
the comic book storyline which I'll talk
about in a second but also how that
holiday is important for the Catholic
faith although a lot of you are like
well if he's being born again
isn't that more of an Easter thing
because that's when Christ was supposed
to be reborn so it wouldn't push the
metaphor that far remember Netflix is
still a business they have to earn money
so they want to push these Marvel
Netflix series out on a schedule so
that's why they aren't waiting till next
Easter be thankful that they decided not
to wait till the big reason why they're
waiting is is because he just presumably
died at the end of defenders they
referenced that during Luke Cage I'll
play that clip in a second but all the
other heroes need to pick up with their
lives like this is what they're doing
after all this defender stuff happened
believing that he's dead it would have
been super weird if they would have had
daredevil season 3 right after defenders
like oh is he dead nope he's definitely
not dead he's back all the other heroes
just need to go on with their lives like
this is how we're affected by what we
just did with this giant hole in the
ground in the dragon bone graveyard
here's the Luke Cage clip referencing
all that stuff you're not invulnerable
Luke Matt wasn't and neither are you
Matt was nothing like me okay you were
more like Matt than you want to admit
trust me I know of course you do because
you're always running when I'm falling
in with people with abilities yeah
Jessica Danny Matt me no matter who how
you always involved this is also
important for Claire temples character
too because this happens relatively
early in the season and Luke kind of
pushes her away she's sort of leaving
the Marvel Netflix series so she's not
gonna be an iron fist
no more Claire temple for the
foreseeable future but she could always
come back later it's because the actress
in real life wants to spend more time
with her children so it's not that
they're killing her off or anything like
that she's still alive she'll just come
back whatever she wants to so Luke Cage
picks up a couple months after defenders
he goes through his arc but as part of
that we see Danny Rand who has evolved a
little bit because of what's happened
really what happened is is that the
writers of Luke Cage and the showrunner
just completely rebooted that character
the way that they saw fit it was amazing
but within the eternal logic of the
series Danny has evolved and become a
better Iron Fist because of that
defenders experience so with the very
end of that we see a post-credits scene
with him in the green tracksuit lighting
his fist up on the
rooftops as you would see daredevil
normally do
and that was just meant to imply that he
was picking up Matt's beep because they
believed he was dead the city needs
defending when he showed up during Luke
Cage season two he said he was defending
Manhattan while Luke was defending
Harlem so his confirmation that he is
officially covering Matt's beat right
now and during the Iron Fist trailer
that we just saw he's talking about a
war that's coming which is sort of their
immortal weapons teaser because Davos is
now probably going to be gaining some
power he's the main villain of season
two but we don't know whether or not
he's become the immortal weapon of one
of the other capital cities of heaven
it's just Danny's time to show that he
can step up so paving the way for
daredevil to come back and be reborn
this Christmas just like Christ was born
at Christmas I know it gets a little
confusing if you take it a little too
literally because like I said Easter was
when Christ was reborn and really the
term born again in Christianity is
usually what you say to people who are
born-again Christians like they get
baptized again late in life to wash away
their sins so if you're not a big comic
book reader daredevil born again is the
process where kingpin tears down Matt
Murdock's real life and his life as
daredevil so remember kingpin does not
know that Matt Murdock is daredevil so
he hates daredevil because he thwarts
all his plans but he hates Matt Murdock
because he's the one that put him behind
bars he already wants to kill both of
those characters but once he learns that
they're the same person
then he really goes into overdrive and
just starts wiping the city clean of
everything Matt Murdock he destroys his
reputation his identity he's taken to
his lowest point which is the
opportunity to be born again so it's
sort of him being baptized by fire and
by dragon bones but it's also the rise
of the kingpin very important too
because Wilson Fisk is probably the best
villain that the Marvel Netflix series
have so even if they don't do defenders
again I'm hoping for a bunch of
crossover where Wilson Fisk just takes
them all on at the same time what'll
probably happen now because there's no
big convention between now and the end
of the year is his Netflix will probably
just drop that daredevil trailer at the
end of iron fist or just a little bit
after they drop all the iron fist
episodes so bare minimum by October
we'll probably see our first official
daredevil season 3 foot
like I said tentatively just set your
clocks for December seventh that first
Friday in December unless they decide to
bump it up by a week because December
first is a Saturday so they might do it
right at the beginning of December but
either way it's gonna be awesome
I know everybody's been waiting for it
like when it's Punisher coming back when
is daredevil coming back so just post
all your reactions in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner John Alexander please email me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details I'll do a new round
when I post new Marvel click here for
all those Infinity Ward's deleted scenes
and click here to learn all about the
new Batman a solo movie thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight